(bell tolling)
- I don't think there is a contradiction
between a simple life and a spicy food.
Perhaps someone who's living a simple life
needs to have something to spice it up.
Maybe that works (laughs).
(peaceful piano music)
My name is Father Richard Walz,
and I am a monk of Subiaco Abbey,
which is a monastery in Subiaco, Arkansas.
After I graduated from high school,
I entered the monastery,
so I've been 55 years a monk.
(men singing)
Monk sauce, which we produce
here at Subiaco Abbey,
is an habanero pepper sauce.
We call that Monk Sauce,
because it's monk-made.
Anybody who has handled habanero peppers
knows that you should not be doing this
without a glove on.
A good monk is a good balance
between prayer and work.
(blender whirring)
That oughta be done.
Wanna find out if it's any good?
Where's the water, huh (laughs)?
I suspect that a lot of people
have kind of fanciful ideas
about monks and what they do,
and they get into the
monastery and they find out
that monks are very much
like everybody else.
(engine hums)
I feel very close connection
to the land in this area.
The longer that I was here,
the more I realized that God got me here
because he knew I ought
to be in a community.
The community is a very
important thing to me.
(peaceful piano music)